[Música]
ah
cuánto dura un minuto
parece una pregunta absurda verdad
pero
y nos preguntamos verdaderamente y
cuánto dura un minuto
verás hay minutos que cambian historias
modifican una vida
y hasta te marcan la piel
y quiero compartir de algo
resulta que durante el verano de 2010
pasé muchas horas trabajando en la
escritura de una novela
llevaba años con la idea dando vueltas
en mi cabeza
pero la idea no terminaba de concretarse
así que en ese verano construí un montón
de versiones
pero
la idea no se cerraba
entonces me dije lilia
todo tiene su límite todo tiene su
tiempo y me propuse
y terminarla antes de un viaje que tenía
un congreso en chile
y eso hice
así que a fin de febrero tomé el avión
con la novela lista pero algo en la
resolución de la trama no terminaba de
conformarme
llegué a chile pasaron varios días de
conversaciones y propuestas en torno a
literatura infantil y juvenil
encuentro con amigos porque habíamos
acordado reunirnos
varios participantes de un posgrado
virtual entonces fueron días de
trasnochadas conversaciones cenas paseos
hasta aquí
el 26 de febrero nos quedaba un solo día
de congreso y esa noche nos fuimos a
dormir con la idea de todo lo que nos
quedaba por hacer antes de regresar a
casa
[Música]
[Aplausos]
queridos todos amados como siempre y
sentidos como nunca imaginarán
estoy muy bien
agradeciendo al sagrado espíritu la
maravillosa gente que me regaló la vida
pero no fue fácil
el terremoto se sintió terrible
nos despertó la noche sobre una
locomotora sobre un tren fantasma que
nos movía el suelo
rita y jose manuel cuando pudieron bajar
de la planta alta llegaron a mi
habitación buscando a su argentinita
y como yo entre sueños no terminaba de
comprender qué sucedía pregunté por qué
evita tu casa anda en tren
fue un chiste del día y repetido cien
veces en casa y entre congresistas
percibo un esfuerzo sobrehumano para
alejarnos del miedo a la muerte
que anda solo apaguen sus medidas entre
los remezones entre cada réplica hacemos
un largo silencio a la espera de que se
duerma que por favor se duerma ese
furioso gigante de hacia abajo
chile es puro coraje
coraje y amor dolor infinito por el
inmenso número de muertos que sube a
cada minuto
me pregunto por qué
porque nuestro mundo se embarca en
cuestiones estúpidas como una guerra si
estamos tan indefensos
con la naturaleza tan incomprensible
como la prehistoria nos alcanza
darnos cuenta de nuestra inmensa
pequeñez
y tu fuerte
idealmente si te mueve el mundo
se te llevará el orden y la lógica
fueron casi tres minutos cargados de
infinito
y veremos cómo se va arreglando el tema
del aeropuerto a esta altura es una
cuestión menor
suficiente con que se quede quieta la
tierra
más allá de todo esto me siento segura
pero no alcanza no hay miedo no
es un sentimiento que todavía no puedo
terminar de resonar
si que llegara a casa un poco antes o
después pero algo muy diferente hay en
mí
hoy se suspendió el congreso pero todos
estuvimos juntos por mucho tiempo
conjurando nuestros temores
hoy vais de abrazo
ahora
con una vibración especial
tengo que confesarles que hizo de las
vibraciones
quiso ponerle honda al susto que
seguramente tenía toda mi familia
pero lo cierto es que nosotros en chile-
seguíamos temblando después del
terremoto
durante 24 horas hubo 203 remezones 203
réplicas dos de esas réplicas fueron
nuevos terremotos
los que miden estos fenómenos aseguran
que este fue uno de los más fuertes de
la historia
el segundo en intensidad en chile
y el séptimo o el octavo registrado por
la humanidad dicen que durante esos tres
minutos la tierra él liberó una energía
semejante a 800 mil bombas atómicas como
la de hiroshima
y junto con toda esa energía además de
moverse las capas tectónicas del planeta
desató lo mejor y lo peor de las
personas
para mejor
todas las seguridades que uno verifica
antes de un viaje
no sería
y el plan de viaje y el pasaje de la
vida
ni la tarjeta de crédito
en las primeras horas no hubo luz
se cortaron las comunicaciones mi
teléfono fijo ni teléfono celular ni
internet
el may que acabo de leer t
tarde 15 horas en poder comunicarlo
se cerraron las fronteras no había un
solo medio de transporte
de manera que el terremoto se convirtió
en un enorme megáfono que puso en escala
al planeta y algunas cosas personales
por ejemplo
entre las personales
puso lupa en esos
últimos meses de escritura
y la novela que a fuerza de apretones a
fuerza de empujones había cerrado antes
del viaje era la historia de dos chicos
que guiados por las travesuras de su
perro
ingresaban a una especie de portal y de
tiempos paralelos
de allí a fenómenos extraños que usaban
un espejo y hasta podían contemplar una
catástrofe natural
para
ambientar esa escena de la novela
durante el verano y antes del viaje
había investigado
y había encontrado que en 2008 había
había habido un tsunami en asia y un
dato había llamado poderosamente mi
atención
el hecho de que los animales días antes
de tsunami
guiados por su sensibilidad habían
comenzado a migrar hacia lo alto de la
montaña
entonces se salvaron
los humanos
por el contrario llevados por la
curiosidad fueron hasta la orilla y se
los tragó la ola
con esa percepción de humanidad dormida
con el gps desorientado
había construido una de las escenas
centrales de mi novela
encima mis personajes eran distantes muy
dos testigos de una situación imposible
de modificar
en chile en mi realidad a flor de piel a
la media hora del terremoto un tsunami
en el sur
y contrariamente al tsunami de asia
se salvaron la mayoría de las personas
a pesar de que fallaron los protocolos
de alerta internacional
a pesar de que hubo confusión en las
comunicaciones que era de noche y todos
dormían se salvó la mayoría de la gente
cuando regrese a casa a los varios días
y lo hice en bus porque los aeropuertos
solo estaban operativos para recibir
ayuda internacional
en el bus tuve oportunidad de leer un
periódico que describía una serie de
gestos valientes y heroicos de una serie
de personas
y entre ellas entre las cosas que
relataba comentaba que una nena de 12
años
al percibir el riesgo y a pesar de su
desconcierto
guiada por una fuerza que ella misma
hasta el día de hoy no puede explicarse
fue corriendo hasta la campana de alerta
y comenzó a hacerla repicar
de esta manera despertó a su pueblo al
vecindario que pudo refugiarse en un
lugar más alto
guau dije
qué maravilla las llamadas poéticas que
nos hace la realidad cierto
cuando llegue a casa
acompañada por 100.000 fuerzas
resonantes comencé a trabajar en la
reescritura de mi novela
los personajes serían los mismos harían
también un extraño viaje pero
si van en una llave para hacerse
preguntas
habría una un guardabarreras un
personaje siniestro que impediría el
paso
con unas manos enormes unas uñas
terribles arañando manoteando robando
vidas
y mis personajes
no andarían azarosamente y por esos
tiempos paralelos seguirían se seguirían
su propio olfato
elegirían sus propios caminos
y decidirían llegar hasta esa isla
robinson crusoe para sumarse al replicar
de las campanas para sumarse a replicar
de la vida
con todas sus fuerzas buscarían vencer
hasta las leyes del espacio del tiempo
lo que había sucedido en aquella versión
del verano
de la novela era que a la resonancia
poética le había querido ganar la
urgencia
la inmediatez el oficio
porque aún en lo que amamos en el
trabajo que amamos
ustedes lo saben hasta en la amistad y
en la pareja hay maneras de hacer las
cosas más o menos bien y en piloto
automático
hasta en la creatividad
y en la escritura hay modos de
traccionar de poner en marcha
procedimientos para llenar el vacío de
una novela que nos llega
entonces las recetas conocidas el camino
que nos falla el plan de escritura
sin duda pueden llegar a ser buenos
ejercicios si nos mantienen en
entrenamiento
pero esa no es mi mejor versión
no sé si es tu mejor versión
yo creo que nuestra mejor versión
resuena más alto
porque de resonar se trata esta
experiencia humana
de honrar la vida se trata como dice una
de las canciones que a mí más me gustan
de la diabla que es ella dice porque no
es lo mismo que vivir honrar la vida
y a mí se me ocurre porque no es lo
mismo que escribir ahorrar la escritura
y porque no es lo mismo que soñar honrar
un sueño
y hacemos la comparación que necesites
porque de resonar se trata y eso
independientemente
del impacto social o la importancia que
supuestamente tenga lo que hacemos
de resonar en los gestos simples
el resonar
es como el aroma de pan fresco
uno no sabe de dónde llega pero viene
la literatura tiene sus propios y si
nuestros caminos
es como resonar
y algunos
y amigos míos dicen que ellos el
terremoto le pasó como si nada
sabes
y las catástrofes naturales o las
catástrofes en general te dejan marcas
en el cuerpo
y cuando yo siento que replican o vibran
los cristales porque simplemente pasó un
camión a un colectivo o cuando estoy en
la boca de un subterráneo y siento que
me sube por los talones ese suave muy
suavecito
tembleque o de la tierra me recuerda
la maravilla está arriba aquí y ahora
algunos amigos míos dicen que ellos el
terremoto le pasó como si nada
viste lo que te toca te toca dicen lo
que importa es que ese toque valga la
pena
y a mí
eso de que la muerte anduviera dándome
vueltas
y a cada ratito
me dijo ate remotada por mucho tiempo
pero además dejó habilitada en mí una
falla que yo llamo la falla de nazca no
existe en la geografía ni en la geología
sólo existe en la geografía interna
y es un espacio abierto a los
movimientos
es un estado de alerta en este oficio
que tenemos de estar vivo
mira
te presto mi terremoto
te lo confió
para que puedas habitar tu propio
resonar
para que en la plenitud de un instante
desafías tus propias construcciones y si
es necesario escriba su historia nueva
de resonar se trata de estabilidad
simple vamos
un poco más alto
[Música]
[Aplausos]